[Musik]
ich will auf der maus wenn das mein
größter kindheitstraum ist auf der
moskau bis neues bauer kolonie gründe
aber ich glaube ich würde doch mit dem
gedanken dass man in zukunft aber
darüber einen besuch bauer dort wenn der
lebensraum von steve shill in erfüllung
geht wird er eines tages auf dem
aussterben
bis all wähler die erde für immer
verlassen
und wie gehen andere mit jemandem der
einen sonderbaren wunsch hat davon
handelt dieser reportage
[Musik]
im pool gab es im primarschulhaus
bichelsee ist heute einer zu gast der
nach den sternen greift ich erkenne mich
momentan in der schule thema weltraum
maß und pleite tour gehörte im jahr 2026
wenn alles klappe auf der maus co ich
bin momentan in meiner
bewerbungsverfahren dienen wo vor über
230 menschen momentan noch 705 welt wie
dem bewerbungsprozess ihnen sind und ich
denke lena verlosen frage was er auf dem
herzen liegt versuch alles beantworten
steve shill gleich um die ecke
aber für die kinder ist sein lebenstraum
jenseits dieser welt ein qaly
lebensmittel machen sondern man muss
einfach wahrscheinlichkeit 400k wohl
aber sexy sind wo kein normales leben
kennt und recht viele von denen sind
selektioniert wurde die institution die
sucht liegt wo gesunder menschenverstand
wo bodenständig sind wo gesund sind und
was leben gern und als ort wo muss ich
mit umbringen wird nicht für so mission
zu klagen
die welt und man möchte den mars
besiedeln das lied irgendwann können
darin dass anstiege auf der man ausflüge
ferien machen oder wenn ihr partner von
monaco gewonnen
in rund zwölf jahren sollen die ersten
vier astronauten den roten planeten
bevölkern
so plant ist die pvp niederländische
organisation maßmann
[Musik]
die acht monate lange reise sowie die
besiedelung sollen live im fernsehen
übertragen werden
ein big brother projekt gar ein
technisch zwar machbar aber verbunden
mit tödlichen gefahren
die kosmische strahlung
durchschnittstemperaturen von -53 grad
kein sauerstoff
dazu sollen um zahn stürme
nur in kapseln der es möglich auf dem
wüstenplaneten nahrungsmittel zu züchten
zwei selektions runden fanden bisher
statt
inzwischen sind nur noch 700 von den
200.000 angemeldeten was kandidaten im
rennen darunter auch der 30 jährige
thurgauer schon als kind war vom
weltraum fasziniert mit der geplanten
auswanderung zum roten planeten will er
seinen kindheitstraum realität werden
lassen
doch so dass die schild zu den
auserwählten zählen wäre dies ein
abschied für immer
denn ein rückflug zur erde ist aus
technischen gründen nicht möglich
zurück bleiben würde dann auch sie seine
verlobte corina küttel familie ziel es
ist wahrscheinlich würden früher oder
später hunger irgendwie zu irgendwelchen
technik sowie der rush hour für die
mission
das tut mir auch nicht so dass hier
alles könnte sogar ich liebe sie über
alles aber also neben liberales
thematische stufe höher
und da setzt sich wieso sie mich kennen
gelernt und wenn ich die möglichkeit
habe die un ist wenig möglichkeit haben
daten gar nicht und was habe ich dir vor
anfang an klar kommuniziert und du bist
stand sie mit
die beiden haben völlig unterschiedliche
vorstellungen was die zukunft betrifft
er will die erde verlassen und sie
erhofft sich irdisches glück durch ein
gemeinsames kind
wenn es regnet würde ihren star nie
wirklich entscheiden und das projekt wie
standorten wahrlich oder tieren die
mutter ich würde trotzdem gewann das
klappt leider situation wirklich anders
aber trotzdem würde sie gab es den plan
trotzdem verwirklichen sich der main
post abschießen kapsel und müsse
umgehend zurück natürlich spielt er das
wirklich ernsthaft jonas spielt das
ganze doch was passiert natürlich stelle
mir das vor und und durch ein sehr
emotionaler mensch bin ja immer mehr
kleine niveaus also das ist es wo ja das
geht
hören sie sich hier ein letztes ding
dann auch schauen dass für das was ist
das magic zwischen freud wo der luft und
für emotionen wenn man die chance hat
aber gleichzeitig auch mal alles der
rückstand der stärke 2 verdrängen
jede küche zeigen und ich behalte mir
dir wenn ihr das hinten aufstellt roten
minivan ich glaube mir nie weiß man
schon mal ich weiß nicht wer denkt da
wird das renommierte wird denkt dass
kinder im alter wenn der papa von
planeta und immer der ton blieb der
eintrag in das sind vielleicht stolz
drauf und die andere sind patrick ich
weiß es nicht
das könnt ihr mir beantworten also mir
-button hier abhauen wie in den letzten
wochen alleine schlug
15 familien und alle sind ja vor allem
die menschen und behinderte gelassen
wenn ich im programm wiederum den gar
nicht mit 24 bis 30 anderen lüth ins
trainingslager
das trainingslager gut zehn jahre und
die der zehn andere person erkennen wo
denn eigentlich wie ihr bruder schwester
für mich wird wo man alles mit einer
macht und mit denen drei anderen übt man
den auf der maas aber noch ist er der
schwerkraft des alltags unterworfen
der gelernte elektriker arbeitet heute
als angestellte eine stelle im
vermittlungs büros am donnerstag frage
zu welchem salat wo bewegen sie sich
momentan als aktuell
und das ist das realistisch ich will
schnell und gut karriere machen für sie
machen
und so lange ich darauf bin mache ich
das und geboren ist aber selbst wenn sie
aus dem haus können wenn sie denn da
weiß die höhe stiegen oder wenn ich
jetzt einfach alles weil ich gelernt
dass ist das ist das macht man nicht
also ich bin mitte wo einfach jetzt
bietet auch das projekt massig hobby
gebe vollgas profi sport da gebe ich
vollgas in winterthur technologie trifft
sich eine internationale truppe der mars
mission
diese menschen träumen davon auf den
mast auszuwandern
steve schild ist nicht nur als kandidat
dabei er hat den heutigen anlass mit
organisiert der thurgauer lässt seine
mitkonkurrenten zu spielerischen tests
antreten
[Musik]
maximal zwei minuten zeit zum luftholen
im boxen und was will der mensch unter
stress
die auswahl der mars bewohner geschieht
über ein mehrstufiges verfahren
diese müssen psychischen druck aushalten
und technische kenntnisse erwerben
die besten anwärter durchlaufen eine
zehnjährige ausbildung in trainingscamps
wo sie in isolations kamen zusammen
leben
die astronauten aspiranten wollen wie 1
columbus eine neue welt entdecken sie
sind beseelt vom gedanken den größten
schritt der menschheit zu vollziehen
ich bin 67 jahre alt es gibt da keine
altersgrenze ich habe ein gesundes herz
und bin in guter verfassung
meine eltern sind bereits gestorben
ich habe zwei brüder und die haben
verständnis für meinen traum
sie haben mir gratuliert und hoffen dass
sich die gelegenheit erhalten werde
auf den mars zu gehen alle zu sterben
plötzlich ist nicht so groß ein
katastrophe ich finde die schlimmste
katastrophe ist wenn langsam die
verlieren alle ihre möglichkeiten zum
leben ihre sauerstoff lebensmitteln die
kühlung nicht so schnell sterben aber
die werden langsam sterben das ist die
schlimmste und das ist eigentlich
passiert in weimar und raumfahrt wo ein
kosmonaut ist hat ewig lang rum herum
die er in orbit gegangen bisher ist
gestorben
auf ihn haben alle gewartet das land
dort der initiator von mars one dem
holländer fehlt noch die kleinigkeit von
sechs milliarden dollar um das projekt
zu realisieren das wohnprojekt ist nun
drei jahre alt und wir sind gut
unterwegs
wir haben bereits verträge mit firmen
für raumfahrt und wir haben kontakt zu
investoren und fernsehstationen die an
den übertragungsrechten interesse haben
es läuft das recht gut auch ihn zieht es
oft in die ferne bin auch nicht gerade
auf den mars stiefvater uhr
er ist seit der scheidung meist im
wohnmobil unterwegs
über europa wie europa zwischen jungen
uhr schild ist im sozialbereich tätig
und arbeitet teilzeit in verschiedenen
institutionen
er fährt mit seinem wohnmobil durchs
ganze land von stelle zu stelle
der 52 jährige und sein sohn hatten
jahrelang keinen kontakt
als ich nach england gelebt moment an
als ich schieße differenzen gelöst
ja ich bin eine die man einfach so okay
aber ich bin auch sehr eigensinnig und
ja und dann hermann pledge das immer den
teller kommt und handhaben der makler
tisch gemacht noch noch als baujahr
seiten so als eine person welche zahlen
die halb ist der mars ja/nein
skrupelloser gangster damit absolut
sofort das heißt sie ihren sohn würde
sich in jene ich sehe ja das problem
nein überhaupt nicht und warum nicht so
gern nach steuern und dritten tag leben
ist und und
man weiß nicht was man selber besiegt
oder im hof wo sie zwei jahren jetzt
hohe mehr oder weniger selber und auch
anders wird das maschinerie egoistisch
klingeln ich sage jetzt haken oder
verstärken die ich mache ich die mission
ich war schon so dass wir sagen ich
würde wäre froh wenn ich die
informationen vielleicht gar nicht hätte
wenn es war als wäre ablenken
es würde mich emotional auch die gefühle
und die sonne ist das ziemlich
anstrengend denn der ddr die
informationen und mittelstufe 8
[Musik]
also wenn sie mal doppel sind
in zukunft ist dass sich das thema also
machen ist ziel der ufa kennt das
manchmal ziemlich hand und das mit der
sichtlich lebe und denke mir alle zwei
jahren vier läufer und die sieht liegt
ihr wachsen immer mehr und ziele gegen
wenn noch ein paar hundert jahre dass
man den oberländer hat das mit ober
sprachzentrum haid und so weiter das
grund alles mit drin
[Musik]
bis zu drei stunden trainiert er täglich
dank seiner fitness sie verstand steve
schild problemlos die ersten zwei
selektions runden
getestet wurden gesundheit und kondition
[Musik]
der hand wenn sie bei mir nicht gott das
recht eigentlich alles was er überhaupt
jemand einmal möglich würde die gurgel
das ist so ja auch mit dem gedanken dass
man bis neues aufbaut und eine vorerst
wird sie das macht das nicht um die
menschheit weiterzubringen nehme jeder
so flink auf sagte er
ich kann es übertrieben westküste
eingeschlagen sportlerinnen bosse sind
aber fast nach belieben jeder will
mehreren us autobauer
ja das ist so aber wir sehen wir geben
dazu könnte in der schweiz war das so
schön gehört die ich da sagen wir es
passiert eine menge liegt das bin ich
das schild leistet sich einen
privattrainer denn er will körperlich
bereit sein
ihre küche arbeitet für den mars
kandidaten trainingspläne aus und
überwacht seine leistungsfähigkeit
bemerkte sie bemerkt aber der körper
funktioniert sehr gut und vita und
überfahren
[Gelächter]
ich sehe aber ich ziehe jetzt aber will
für mich der typische ausstrahlt ist ein
projekt diene jetzt so extrem sensibel
ist wenn er aber weg seit er weiß was er
will und das ist wichtig für mich und
ich glaube ihm das nicht nur spitze
sondern sie 100 prozentig und er hat
zentral und ich am hintern
das nächsten des feuers frische luft
kollegen auch das wären bloß noch
erinnerungen würde seinen traum in
erfüllung gehen
jörg 30 und kevin wieso tun sich schwer
mit tiefs plänen und trotzdem mails
studioversion mission und genau was es
an sich kreis so krumme gibt und die
normalen auto der top 8 rang oder im
sind da ist doch irgendwie ein
widerspruch es ist wenn man wenn man
darüber nachdenkt ist mir schon mal
super nicht für immer die tore
geschlossen
nach unter druck da man sich schon mal
black java-software freundschafts
wertvoll wäre an sich wollte die solo
karriere
okay aber trotzdem unterstütze die
haltung steht zu hören ja nicht der
hoffnung dass es wieder klappen
das an sich ist ihm egal
jetzt weiß ich hoffe einfach dass du
nicht zu erwarten wir morgen und
herzlich beste werder-profi für sein
projekt das mit der gedanke gar nicht
dass das passiert ich deinen stil und da
der weg und fokussiere mich ich bin mega
gern durchs leben und tun aber ich finde
mich mit dem wir dann kann auch das wenn
ich der dumme wäre darum bestellt noch
leben auch nicht dass ich nie machen du
sogar natur leben einfacher so schnell
den wald gebaut
was machst du wenn es nicht schafft wenn
das nimmt wird dann eine ganz viele
andere idee was wird der gott und
irgendwann werde ich eines tages im
weltraum das ziel blieb praktisch nur
wir nicht denn das erreichen wird ach so
ich ins bett das war lebenstraum erfüllt
und dass man positiv denkt aber sicher
schon mal laut metro
danke für malaysia dürfte demnächst muss
tief sind eine weitere
entscheidungsrunde verstehen
geprüfte diesmal seine belastbarkeit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
o